thank you for joining me so early in the
morning this is ungodly early for me
based in San Francisco so I'm glad
y'alls are strapping in uh we're gonna
speedrun speed run some parts of this
but videos will be posted in case you
know you don't understand what I'm
saying okay
um so let's just go ahead and get
started so
uh so if you're here in this room uh
you're here just now room check right
make sure you're in the correct room uh
we're here to talk about a few things
number one
problems in ml Ops and with the moabs
number two uh we're gonna talk about
some common tools uh that are kind of
being used in some Stacks uh we're gonna
specifically focus on open source tools
especially ones that I've kind of come
up in the last two three years that
maybe y'alls are not you know familiar
with or just need to be reminded about
and then we're going to at the end I'm
going to talk about some Stacks that I
think folks can kind of like customize
and personalize in a very proud
pragmatic way to like y'all's particular
needs
okay
uh so how we're gonna do this
um I'm going to remind us of what were
the original Promises of mlops like what
are we actually supposed to be doing
uh we're gonna talk about like what are
the actual like pain points or where the
the jobs to be done by data scientists
uh we're going to describe the kind of
different requirements of like if you're
a solo data scientist you're a data
science team or uh even a data science
org in like in an Enterprise company
um and then I'm going to propose some
Stacks which you know they they could be
implemented in a week and even a day uh
but your mileage will vary
okay so first off uh who am I
uh so my name is mikiko Baisley uh you
can call me Mickey like Mickey Mouse
mouse ears uh so I'm currently head of
mlops uh at feature form which is an
open source uh feature store
um in my role there I get to work with a
variety of different companies both
International Enterprises uh to even
startups who are all kind of figuring
out this like first like question of how
do we design our ml platform
uh before I was at feature form uh I was
working on the platform team for mlops
at MailChimp as a matter of fact I have
a former colleague Emily who will be
doing a talk two talks from now so you
should stay in this room and listen uh
she is awesome
um before mlops uh at MailChimp I was
doing various roles working either data
science data analytics or what I like to
think of it as working the full value
chain of data to ml
um
I've also worked at a bunch of different
startups and all that uh other fun facts
I am based in born and raised in San
Francisco uh my quarantine habit that I
picked up was customizing sneakers so I
just have a bunch of random like janky
Jordans all over my apartment my partner
cannot stand them especially since I
keep buying more
um I do write a lot I am very interested
in all these topics in an almost
unhealthy fashion so just check out my
sub stack if you're really interested
and I studied anthropology in college uh
so studying monkeys gave me just really
great insight into how humans operate
with technology not so different from uh
chimps and sticks occasionally
um okay
so current landscape
oh
I'm sure we all recognize this uh map
but if you don't it's Matrix mad
landscape
2023 Edition uh there are some
inclusions of General AI startups and
also some Consultants Seattle day guy on
the mark data Mark Freeman and also our
friends over at uh ternary uh Matt and
Joe so congrats for them to making the
map but this is what it looks like
I know I look at it and I'm just like
anxiety and panic induced and I'm sure
for many of y'alls who are like in your
like buy build evaluation phase you
probably feel like this too that or
you're a psycho uh so this is what it
used to look like hypothetically right
it might not include everything but wow
we've like massively expanded
uh okay so more options more tools
that's you know always a great thing
right the jam experiment they did was
like more jams made people like happier
right
it did not actually that was that was
the outcome more choices did not in fact
make people happy but like how do we
even get here
Okay so
what was the original promise of ml Ops
exactly
starting timer sorry forgot about that
um Okay so
ml Ops a lot of people like think it
basically kicked off unofficially in
2015 with the publication of the high
interest credit card debt paper by D
Scully and friends and then two years
later we had the test score paper which
attempted to define a collection of best
practices especially software
engineering best practices for
productionizing machine learning uh in a
way that was scalable it was repeatable
it was resilient
um and essentially like this is we were
trying to get to a very seamless pattern
of you design it you train it and you
run it
essentially like if we put in more
technical terms right we are essentially
trying to figure out like or improve
three different dimensions the first one
was velocity how fast are machine
learning models being developed how fast
are the gangs shipped out the door
that's always a good thing right more
projects more money for business uh
throughput which is like essentially how
much Innovation can you just like shove
through the pipeline
and third most importantly risk
especially in monitoring and evaluation
right we essentially did not want to put
out models that were terribly racist and
bigoted uh we also want them to work so
this was the original sort of uh goals
of Emma lops
uh but sometimes it kind of feels like I
don't know it feels like we kind of left
some folks behind you know sometimes it
feels like there's something that's a
little bit missing
so we've essentially kind of in my
opinion we've really failed the original
like consumers of mlops tooling which
was Data scientists
over an amylopson ml systems land you
know we've been going Gaga over like
complex diagrams uh we love talking
about like oh should a notebook even you
know should a notebook be used by data
scientists should be put into production
uh oh how fast can we speed up latency
using XYZ in memory store
all right we love all these different
topics and that's fantastic there's a
lot of parts of the ecosystem that we've
managed to build out and optimize
um
okay so but what are data scientists
like actually experiencing
maybe they've got issues with versioning
and you know lots of different name
notebooks
uh maybe they have issues with like
collecting and creating these data sets
uh with data Transformations and feature
engineering
from the perspective of a data scientist
and even from the platform Engineers
that support them this is the reality
insufficient data documentation
tribalism siloing Dev prod environment
mismatch
these are like we can go on and on and
on this is just three papers that were
published on ML Ops in the last two
years uh if you're interested in the
recommendations just let me know
and I can tell you like in office hours
or whatever
Okay so
there's a lot of challenges I mean some
of these can definitely be solved by
tooling
um and I could jump straight into like
telling you what Stacks I think are
really cool uh you know take my opinion
or leave it
but here's the thing
um in my experiences both like as an IC
working as a data scientist working on a
platform team even trying to bootstrap
like in early stage like real estate
Tech data startup in the middle of
quarantine God that was just such a bad
move it was interesting but it was not a
great move
um so I've had a lot of experiences
working with practitioners and Builders
and there are things that we could be
doing differently regardless of what
tech stack we use regardless whether
you're using redis you're using
um any other like competitor you're
using snowflake or duckdb there are
certain practices we should be doing so
what are these three practices
okay so so the first off is treating the
ml platform as a product like having
that mindset that's something that
really is kind of missing
so what are the characteristics of a
product so when I think of a product and
probably when you think of a product
there's a couple things that stick out
first off it has an owner and it has
users or customers
there are people or teams uh that are
behind it that are focused on for
example developing developing it so that
it number one does what it needs to
right you don't essentially want your
Spotify player essentially acting like
tick tock well okay they're doing that
now but still right
um it evolves it matures
and ideally it's long-lived
the iPod or the original iPhone ideally
outlived the original creators who then
went on to other companies right
um
when we think of this as apply to
platforms
then that implies a couple things right
one uh it's quick and easy to start
should be easy to use
uh secure and compliant obviously that's
just Table Six
we're not going to argue with that
um there's an internal Community there
are people who like champion in
uh with products even though they are
long lived in Silicon Valley terms a
platform should be up to date should be
relevant
and a very very important uh
characteristic of platforms or products
uh is they are uh opt-in they are not
forced
the minute you try this is how we get
Shadow ID the minute you try forcing
something on a data science team or even
an engineering team uh watched and
watched them like try to find you know
obstacles around it right
so if we think about our platform as a
product
this implies certain things
as Engineers we do really really well at
measuring things like infrastructure
for example like serving serving latency
number of instances a number of like
jira tickets that are filed we're really
really good at that we've kind of you
know figured out a bunch of stuff we
could do there
but a lot of times what teams are really
missing is these top two layers for
example when you think of a product as
like a growth marketer or a product
manager you're thinking about weekly
active users engagement adoption rate I
mean for a lot of platform teams uh do
you even know like who's using your like
platform like do you have that kind of
telemetry
do you know what they're doing with your
platform
essentially like we've been really good
at building out apis tools Services uh
collecting them occasionally into like
pseudo platforms but we kind of like
leave out on this unified experience
right like it should be all together
people should not be jumping through
like Hoops as if it's like the old
school Nickelodeon battle games or
battle shows
okay so second thing this is related to
platform as a product uh enablement
right it's the thing that we all kind of
are like yeah well let's just ship it
and then we'll kind of like do an office
hour and then people will get it and if
they read our documentation they don't
get it they're dumb heads
right
that's how we think of it
and for law folks this is how you know
like data scientists are thought of
they're either thought of as like these
like mad Geniuses or these people who
are like I paid for a boot camp why
didn't I get a six-figure job
I was a boot camp grad so I'm allowed to
make that joke by the way
um
I'm not just picking on folks right
um so enablement is a very manual
process right yes you have qualitative
data and metrics but you also need to do
um or quantitative but you also need to
do the qualitative like manual
approaches like asking these questions
like if you don't know the answers to
these questions about your users using
our platform I would argue that one
you're not user-centric
and two you kind of just did resume
driven development
don't worry I've been there too
so but why is it important even to do
like user surveys why is that like the
first thing they tell startups to do in
developing a product
well for one thing is because you might
not actually know who your customer user
is
for example uh and a lot of folks have
probably observed this like themselves
data scientists tend to be a lot more
diverse not only in a field of study so
they tend to come from more places
uh as well as prior job titles even more
so than data engineers
and the third best practice that uh we
need to be doing before we even like
think about like Stacks or making like
decisions uh is our North Star
right OG user is data scientists uh much
like the talk that's going on about chat
gbt and how like oh copilot is making
every like engineer like a 10x engineer
this is what should be going on with our
data science like platforms or our ml
platforms or ml platforms whatever you
call it right
we should be making every data
scientists A 10x data scientists it
should be a seamless experience
I said an f word but I didn't actually
by the way that's what the pause was
there's a couple things that should be
going on first off uh it should be
solving cognitive overload
it should be cutting friction and
increasing flow
these are the two mandates of platforms
we should not be enabling this
we were just talking about Oracle in
this diagram
um okay so there's a lot of stuff out
there
raise your hand if your platform is
basically S3 spark and redis and Bash
Plus kubernetes
and python
yeah there we go come on guys I know you
all like Pi spark yeah
and hey you know what there is no shame
in that game don't want to don't let
anyone say that you know you shouldn't
be using those
um those are great tools and I'm not
going to knock on like that layer of the
stack for one thing I'm not smart enough
um
but there are certain classes of
problems that they don't solve
uh so roughly speaking
if I were to apply a scientific method
right
which this isn't uh so there's two
different kinds of layers of problems
right the first problem is
we call it the platform we're kind of
figuring out the name but it's really
like the infrastructure like the core
components the modules the services
right it's things for example like redis
snowflake duct DB kubernetes Ray you
name it
um it's figuring out the technical
challenges how do we make it faster how
do we make like increase the throughput
yada yada right but there's this other
class of problem that lays lives on top
of it which is like workflows
what is like the right set of operations
for how someone should proceed with
their model uh what is the like handoff
look like
um we all know that we need monitoring
but maybe for example people need
monitoring at different times how do we
like essentially codify these things
into like a happy path
right specifically what I'm talking
about is the problems around the like
data science jobs to be done or the
problems to be solved
we've been really good about that so
let's dig in a little bit deeper on the
like Ops or how to map tools to your
problems
okay so data science jobs to be done
um man that buy build like evaluation
decision thing it is tough it's tough
especially like
and it doesn't matter what stage you're
at whether you're early stage and you're
a solo data scientist whether you're
mid-size as a team whether you're an
Enterprise the bill by the build by Best
of redecision is never never easy
um so what I'd like to do is try to like
kind of come up with a framework for
like how I like to think about like
stacks
which ideally should hopefully help you
with tools right
um okay
so there's two Dimensions I like to
think about
we'll start with the First Dimension
which is the ml life cycle
so we can kind of separate out the data
scientists like jobs be done roughly in
like four stages
so stage one which I like to call the
data everything
stage or like the data set engineering
not to be confused with data engineering
data Ops uh there's a couple things
going on right first off uh as a data
scientist you are getting your data
you're curating it into a single data
set that you can work on
that was one of the hardest problems
still
right in a mops
you're analyzing that data you're seeing
if there's some initial signals or
Trends or even a lot of times if you
could just kind of stop the project
there and not even go to model mode
Sometimes the best model is the model
that's not built
uh and then you also have feature
engineering and feature serving right so
that's the first step first collection
uh the second collection of jobs we've
done or you know tasks for a data
scientist is the small experimentation
and training phase
right so you have like your data you
have your set of features and labels if
it's a supervised uh learning problem
and then what you're doing is you're
experimenting with different
combinations of the mall algorithm uh
different like features uh hyper
parameter tuning sometimes they're even
experimenting with like Ensemble models
right
so you're going to be doing that
in that stage
next you have your model
you're going to deploy and serve it
ideally this should be relatively smooth
like I know for a lot of people it's not
and then once you've deployed in survey
like the job doesn't end there you do
want to Monitor and like evaluate it and
hot take in case anyone cares uh so if
you are a company that cares about like
llms like and you're going hard on that
and you're not going hard on monitoring
evaluation uh it's called being on the
hype train so hot take there you should
be caring about the stage especially if
you're doing the whole like large
language models right
so those are the four stages
the second axis is level of abstraction
uh
so the layers go from a heart I'm going
to list layers and then we're I'm just
going to work through an example to make
it a little bit easier layer zero is
Hardware layer one is your compute
Frameworks Layer Two Services layer 3 is
workflow and layer Force platform
so let me explain it and let me kind of
work down
so you are a team you're you've got your
ml stack
so the top layer you might have like a
single framework or a sync or an Integra
an integration framework that like spans
the entire life cycle of your model
it manages the different kind of
workflow layers
underneath
um this helpfully is like the first uh
unified interface for your data
scientist it also codifies like how
machine learning is done at your company
uh
layer three workflows
let's use the example of the data set
engineering slash data everything
category of jobs
okay which includes the uh data analysis
and feature engineering and serving
uh so for your workflow you might have
some kind of orchestrator that will
manage at layer three
essentially the transformation that
occurs like in Layer Two maybe through
spark right maybe spark is your like
transformation engine
and then maybe you also have like a
couple others right there used you want
a single orchestrator workflow that that
manages that
uh spark whatever you're using
is essentially it can live on top of a
general computing framework for example
like kubernetes array very common
pattern
uh that's your layer one
and then layer zero it's your Hardware
it's your computer storage right
so these are the two Dimensions I like
to think about your ml stack
and
when you put it together
you start to build out like what are the
prompts to be solved for like the data
science workflows and also to get malls
to production like you start to build
out what your actual stack is
I see people want to take pictures so
I'm just going to pause this here so you
can
foreign
we'll also release the slides too
so you can get that in more detail as
well um but if you want it for now
uh okay so
I was like it might be easier if I walk
but I refuse to lovely or so okay uh
let's just kind of work left to right so
that single example I was taking of like
the feature orchestrator and like the
feature store and transforming features
and all that good stuff
we're now going to extend that to uh the
other stages of the uh ml life cycle
so layer 0 and layer one
which is your Hardware your compute
framework
um
for example like layer zero you might
use a cloud provider uh for Leo layer
zero and one for example you might use
like a serverless GPU provider like
banana like modal
okay
um
roughly speaking like layer zero layer
one that is going to span most of the
company that's just not that's just not
an ml specific problem right or an ml
specific like tooling to be like used
um you're gonna essentially use like
whatever is being provided for your
software Engineers for your data
Engineers we're we're not touching that
right okay so layer two three and four
that's kind of where the the magic of
like the mL of the ml stack mop stack
actually happens
so we'd already talked about uh the
first set which is the data everything
including like feature engineering
um we talked about how like you have
your Layer Two Services uh you have some
kind of like feature engine or feature
service that's then going to be
orchestrated through like a layer 3
orchestrator
let's then go to the next stage which is
like the mall experimentation training
uh so at Layer Two you're gonna have
some kind of like training service or
framework uh might be Pi torch might be
uh what have you
um you might for example use
um you might want to do experiment
tracking for hyper parameters
right so essentially that's something
that like has to be done a data
scientist has to train the model they
have to be the one to run the
experimentation it's not a data engineer
it's not like it's ideally not the
envelopes engineer either it's not the
platform engineer
um and they're gonna essentially like
need help with that workflow they're
gonna essentially need help like using
that service uh using some kind of like
workflow orchestrator or the experiment
like Management Service or workflow
sorry I'm mixing up the terms uh yeah
I'm tired uh
next stage uh stage three which is
deployment serving
uh you're gonna want some kind of path
to production whether it's for example
like your model as like embedded in a
Docker container or what have you and
you're going to want uh a service to
like help manage that and so on and so
forth right
just to make this like super Crystal
Clear I've put some examples up here
uh so for example your services would be
like Duck DB redisk Cassandra uh
snowflake spark uh for training your
service might be like Desi AI with their
super gradient Library it might be
mosaic
if your deployment serving uh you might
have like selling core
you might use Bento ml
um
for valuation y logs log stash and then
you have a bunch of these servers these
workflows that live on top of that
where ideally they can connect with
multiple different providers uh within
the lower layers and then at the top you
have like the orchestrators of
orchestrators or the soup orchestrators
so Q flow flight metaflows nml there's a
bunch that I'm missing but you know like
there is a lot of logos on the magic
landscape
Okay so
so like I had promised some stacks
uh okay so let's talk through
how we're going to essentially like
apply this framework and also see kind
of where it breaks down
okay so needs of the solo data scientist
who are you
uh well the solo data scientist uh
ideally is
they're not like the very first hire
before a data engineer but they might be
they might also be they are definitely
being hired before there is like a
centralized platform effort
um I've been in those shoes I know a lot
of folks here probably have
um so your goal as a data scientist is
you're trying to prove immediate value
like with minimal overhead for your
startup right you're just trying to ship
stuff uh in a way that doesn't totally
break things you're probably also not in
a position to frankly make uh build by
decisions you're just like
I gotta like go
so you have a couple different needs
that are super super important uh at
this stage so for example you need to
keep track of your own stuff like you
need to make sure your house is like
super clean
um data model code artifacts including
experimentation runs
um and ideally you'd like to do it in a
way where you're not naming a bunch of
notebooks and you have a bunch of like
GitHub gifs going like oh yeah go do
this so you you need versioning and
documentation
um you need a way to quickly like
iterate between features algorithms and
like tuning
um you need experiment tracking sure uh
but you need to like be able to just
kind of go on your own accord
uh you shouldn't be blocked ideally
um you need to train malls on like a
large enough amount of data with access
to gpus probably if you need that
um and then you need to do everything
with the least amount overhead possible
with least amount of steps and a lot of
times you're on an island you're on your
own entering is not going to help you
they're just going to be like go figure
it out
so I like to call it the Duke Nukem
stack
uh this is maybe dating folks already I
can see who the gen's ears are
um okay
all these Stacks by the way it's not
gospel I'm just giving an initial set of
guidelines right
okay so what are the characteristics of
the Duke Nukem stack uh well we
mentioned a couple things right one is
minimal overhead two compatibility with
the existing product stack uh your
efforts should not be like severely
diverging at this point
and the hot take is like yo notebooks
are fine okay let's just let's just
chill out on that
um
those are not the arguments we should be
having uh a couple different features so
if we go like left to right uh and then
also top to bottom right
um layer zero and layer one you're not
making decisions there
um but you still need access to
computation
and you could do this in a number of
different ways I've listed some folks
here that are like Notebook based right
uh we have paper space we have collab uh
we also have uh code spaces
um is an option
if we look at Layer Two and layer three
uh for your data storage
needs you're gonna just gonna you're
just gonna use whatever your company has
or you could use for example like Duck
DB
um for like your small enough data small
enough and big enough
right uh you might want to you might
want to like track your features you
might want to document them uh you might
also want to serve them for future
models so you could use a feature store
like feature form it's open source
actually everything here for the most
part is open source except for the stuff
that uh two areas where you like pay for
effectively
right for computation uh renting time is
not cheap uh
yeah and then okay so we go to mall
experimentation training uh look I like
I said I think notebooks are fine
honestly
uh you're going to want to use a tool
like comets or wandb for experiment
tracking both those are perfectly fine
uh you're not super worried right now
honestly about like your Mall registry
you can park it in an S3 bucket whatever
it works uh okay so for deployment
serving
you're ideally not doing anything super
fancy with this you're not doing real
time or streaming uh you're probably
gonna be okay with like a batch uh
prediction where you know like you make
the predictions and then you just do a
lookup from like a table
or cash of some kind uh you might do
like a live service uh if you want to
containerize it but it's not like super
necessary right now right you're just
proving business value you're you're
proving the initial value of using ml
for your product
for the company but you'd still like a
path to deployment and so Bento ml it's
an open source solution uh is totally
great for that need
and then same deal with like monitoring
and your logs
um You probably just need something that
the company already has or that's good
enough for now and you could use
something like log stash and for your CI
CD
I mean use whatever they have once again
it could be Jenkins it could be like
Travis CI build kite or GitHub actions
okay so that was the Duke Nukem stack
not super sexy or exciting uh given the
name but it works and uh surprise that's
going to be like all these Stacks here
like
they're pragmatic they're not super sexy
I'm not trying to shove like totally new
things at you
um okay needs of the SMB data science
team so uh who are you
well minimum you probably have like five
data scientists it's a good number uh
y'alls are collaborating you're sharing
knowledge uh and things like that uh
minimum like let's say 5DS scientists
maximum maybe you're like at the 10-day
scientist and you have like a single
director
right
okay so what are your needs going to be
uh well first off it's you've got a
bunch of different people that ideally
are working with each other uh they're
collaborating uh and of course tribal
knowledge and silos start developing
kind of at this stage pretty quickly
so you need help with collaboration uh
you need to be able to like show the
work in progress
um you also need to be able to like
document the work so you're not being
pinged and slack going like hey by the
way does anyone remember like this table
that tracks like user click streams off
of like you know Google analytics Camp
you know marketing campaigns and all
that
um so you need like a place to get async
knowledge and uh for new people to like
immediately get started um who had that
like experience of getting started at a
company and then they're like oh yeah
just go check Confluence and they're no
one confluences where knowledge goes to
die
um you also need to like like you
ideally you'd like to share and reuse
like sources you don't want to be
rewriting the same like data pipeline
over and over again uh and then racking
up whatever like bills
um find remodeling evaluation this is
where it is actually going to start to
matter because with five data science
for example you have at least five
models Sometimes some of our uh
customers even have up to like a hundred
for like five or ten data scientists
it's crazy you're really going to need
fine green monitoring you're going to
need to find out um first off Which
models are misbehaving uh you're also
going to want to figure out like what
are how are the conditions changing like
detecting day drift before they screw up
so
let's talk about the serious business
stack
um
uh okay so how's it different from the
solo data scientist
uh well there's a couple different
things uh one uh you Mart you might
start really differentiating the kinds
of providers you have including for
example you might have an offline and
online uh store provider
you might also be uh selling behind a
couple different Frameworks for example
like spark but you might add others too
there are others that exist outside of
spark uh so you're going to need a
solution that is able to start mapping
the multitude of providers you're going
to start developing
especially on the data side so you can
still use speechworm for that
um okay on the mall experientation
training site so this is where we start
seeing differentiation in terms of the
types of like serving patterns so it's
no longer just like batch but maybe now
you also need like a live service where
you have a pre-chain a pre-trained model
um that you then expose behind like an
API endpoint and then that needs to
provide like real-time stuff like let's
say for example you need like
recommendations like as you're like
shopping
awesome uh and then so you're gonna have
a couple different like serving patterns
as a container uh you might still do
batch uh you're going to want to start
really thinking about the layers one
layer zero about the general computation
uh Frameworks a very common pattern that
we're starting to see now actually with
our customers is uh using like Ray on
top of kubernetes
um you're still going to want to use
something like Mento Bento also has an
option called yatai so that's going to
be really good for
um scaling on kubernetes
um y Labs Etc but the most the key part
though is you're going to want to start
thinking about that unifying framework
right because now you have like five to
like 10 data scientists uh you're going
to want to start codifying the like the
way the company does things
um and so you can use a framework like
xenamel and some of the other ones I
mentioned too earlier
oh God Enterprise yeah we all remember
what that was like
uh okay so
what's going on like everything
Enterprises have like many of everything
they have many store providers many
products many Monitoring Solutions uh
you name it so they have a very uh
heterogeneous infrastructure in
heterogeneous infrastructure and data
uh governance Access Control audit logs
okay so basically like you start
worrying about things like GPR HIPAA if
you're in medical uh CCPA
um you really start getting worried
about being sued uh and it's funny
because there's even like less
transparency in Enterprise so you have
more risk but you also have no real way
of like figuring it out
hypothetically law of tools offer that
now
um cross-functional workload workflows
is really important you start seeing for
example like pods data scientists
embedded in product teams uh and you
start getting that like super heavily
Matrix company when I was over at
Autodesk uh they had a layoff that laid
off like 13 of the workforce and we
still had 53 products after that before
that we had 70 plus and they have they
have built stuff but most of the
companies were acquired
um
so it was a mess uh if there was a stack
uh we would call it the olly olly oxen
free snack this is what my boyfriend
says every single time I go into a
handbag shop
um so okay there's no stack here uh I
lied
um no but that's this is to say that
like you can still apply like the
framework to kind of figuring out and
mapping the tools to your requirements
um it's just usually as a as a team
you're probably I don't see your siled
into like one area of the stack but you
just have to like think more
strategically about like okay I have
this pain point or bottleneck here and I
need to now solve out or up or down
um so just hopefully this provides a map
to how to get there
okay so hot take there will be no modern
mop stack I know I'm making everyone sad
uh but I think this is like a very very
healthy thing
um
because a lot of companies they do have
truly unique requirements and they're at
different stages and honestly my whole
point with this talk was I had a
conversation with someone on Twitter who
was like uh isn't like like she's she's
asking like well what's the need for a
feature store right and she's like isn't
it just like for real time and if you
need XYZ things I'm like yeah sure like
the initial like all all categories of
tools right uh Mall training
experimentation evaluation
um
uh the data set engineering section
right yeah like the envelopes tools of
five years ago yeah they they did look a
certain way
um but they have updated now and you
know options are good but
um they can be overwhelming so I hope
honestly if there is anything you take
away from this talk it's also just that
like table or that framework
uh so in closing
um
we talked about all these things but
look uh it is really confusing and the
Beautiful part is uh
as like a product developer or as
someone who wants to do ml as a business
you have so many more tools to be able
to do that but more importantly as
practitioners if you're a platform
engineer or a data scientist like you
have the knowledge necessary to pick
your own tools for yourself
um I know it's ridiculous to think about
like Emma Watson notebook but that is a
hundred percent doable right and Wallops
doesn't have to be this big scary thing
that is mandated by a company it can be
something you just do for yourself right
um especially for the solo day assign a
stack like I use that like
on my own too right so there is hope and
more importantly you can get involved in
the open source Community you can help
build contribute
um you can kind of create the future
that you'd like to see
yeah and that's it uh feel free to chat
with me during officers and uh QR codes
connect me on LinkedIn
so yeah that's done
[Music]